have you ever tried to read a book in a
foreign language only to find yourself
endlessly switching between reading the
text and looking up words in a
dictionary what if there were a way to
remove the process entirely and make
reading fast and fun even for beginners
believe it or not there is such a way
and that's what I'll be showing you here
today
hi I'm Lucas I'm a Language Coach who
speaks 14 languages and on this channel
I help people learn foreign languages
more efficiently faster and in a fun way
so how can you read any book in any
language fast while having fun
let's find out
one of the biggest obstacles towards
reading in a foreign language is that
beyond the beginner level written
language gets very difficult very
quickly if you've not reading a text
written specifically for language
Learners you likely have a very hard
time understanding what's going on this
problem arises because in most languages
with a strong literary history the
vocabulary used in writing is often
significantly different from the
vocabulary mostly used when speaking if
you're only used to speaking the
language then reading the language will
expose you to hundreds or even thousands
of words that you've likely never seen
or heard before
if you've never tried your hand on
reading a book magazine or newspaper
article in your target language then
this experience was probably very
frustrating if not completely
demoralizing in these situations it's
easy to feel completely lost even if you
decide to turn to a dictionary for help
the process of looking up unknown words
is so slow and laborious that you're
unlikely to stick with it for very long
no matter which way you approach it
reading authentic texts in your target
language just feels impossible that is
until now fortunately for us language
Learners the folks over at Google have
created a free and easy to use tool that
helps you translate any target language
text at the click of a button yes even
text you find in a physical newspaper or
magazine this tool is called Google lens
and in just a few moments we're going to
take an in-depth look at how it works
let's Dive Right In so I have here in
front of me this fat nice book and it's
in Russian it's it by Stephen King and I
have my smartphone here that I'm going
to use in order to read this book and
understand it immediately let's get
started so as you can see here you can
see the content of the book we are at
chapter 14 at the beginning and I'm
holding my iPhone in my hand all I need
to do is to click on the Google icon
here and then I'm going to click again
on the camera icon there you go and then
the Google opens directly the Google
Lens app
and all I need to do is to scan the page
and here you have to be cautious and you
have to pay attention to take the
content exactly the content you want to
translate and then I just have to push
to click on the button in the middle as
you can see here the Google Lens shows
the text and then all I have to do is to
click on the translate button here and
it's translating it from the language
the language that you know the app will
recognize into English you can even
choose the other languages in this case
I've selected English but I could choose
Italian polish etc etc so as you can see
here the app has translated the text and
the amazing thing about this is that you
can even play the audio which is a game
changer because if you couldn't play the
audio it would be still fine to have a
bilingual text next to each other you
would have it in Russian here you would
have it in English here but it's really
cool to listen to the text in English
while you're reading it in Russian let
me let me give you a demonstration how
this works all you need to do is to
click on the asculta button in asculta
in Italian means listen
chapter 14 album as it turns out bill is
not left alone they all come bill has
bourbon Beverly has vodka and a bag of
orange juice Richie has a six pack of
beer Ben Hanscom has a bottle of Wild
Turkey whiskey and Mike has a six pack
six pack calf Brack comes in last with a
small brown paper bag so I you can click
on a stop
and this allows you to to read the text
in Russian and listen to it and stop
whenever you can and look at how easy it
is to do that I'm holding the book here
uh with my left hand or I'm just like
touching it and I'm for example pointing
at the other words and at the same time
I'm listening to it in English and it's
a very decent translation so this is
fantastic and on top of that as you can
see here you can always you can even
select the text itself now it's selected
apart but I can make sure that I select
all of it and if you want to you can
copy the text or you can simply copy the
text copy it into your computer so this
allows you to directly move this text
from paper into your computer if you
want to so this is very handy as you can
imagine because it's easy to use it's
very quick to use and you can use it in
a number of combinations and remember
that if you want to you can even click
here on text again and bring it back to
the Russian content original content and
listen to it
so as you can imagine this is a game
changer because it allows you to do a
lot of things you can read the text in
Russian so in your target language and
listen to it in your target language you
can read it in Russian while you can
listen to it in English or your native
language and then of course this makes
it so much easier to understand and
there are other features that you can
look into if you want to but just if you
use it this way this is a big game
changer which is going to allow you to
read anything that you want to in your
target language and understand it
immediately
so that's how you can use Google Lens to
translate any target language text in
mere seconds we're just about done here
but before we go let's recap everything
we discussed in this video making the
jump from Reading content made for
Learners and reading content made for
natives can often be extremely
frustrating even for intermediate
Learners and Beyond traditionally
Learners wanted to practice reading
would have to spend time switching
between reading texts and looking up
unknown words in a dictionary a long and
inefficient process now we have a very
different strategy Available To Us by
using an app called Google Lens you can
translate any target language text into
your native language or a language you
know well in seconds using only your
computer or phone once you've translated
a text using Google Lens you can do like
I do and store newly learned words in a
notebook for safe keeping and easy
review if you'd like to learn more about
how I develop my reading skills in
foreign languages at the intermediate
level and Beyond check out my overcoming
the intermediate Plateau course there I
share everything you need to know about
tackling authentic reading materials not
to mention all of the other techniques I
share for listening writing and speaking
to
I'll see you in the next video thanks
for watching and as always happy
language learning